all right very big news yesterday and we
have to give praise to congresswoman
corey bush
for really pushing for this this i would
call this a progressive victory of sorts
even though it may be struck down by the
supreme court relatively quickly
the cdc has extended the eviction
moratorium we talked about this last
week we talked about this uh a bunch of
times because it's a really important
issue
the cdc has issued a new eviction ban
based on the pandemic effective through
october third
the former moratorium expired last month
as we covered
there were 11 million americans behind
on rent as the delta variant
surges this will be targeted at areas of
the country experiencing high levels of
infection from coronavirus it will last
60 days until october 3rd
and the protection could cover around 90
percent
of renters now this may be struck down
and i think that you know i'm giving you
both sides of it this
is really a progressive victory and cory
bush deserves a lot of credit she was
instrumental in pushing this to happen
at the same time there is a big supreme
court threat
uh that this um will not hold the
um there is a politico article which
calls it a potential clash
with the supreme court and what's at
issue here
is whether the cdc uh really has
the authority to do this and it may well
uh the answer that the supreme court
comes up with
may be no joe biden yesterday said he
went to constitutional scholars to find
out about the cdc's legal authority
and what they do that is most likely to
pass muster constitutionally and biden
said the bulk of the scholarship
suggested this would not pass muster in
the courts
but there were some scholars that said
it could
this targeted moratorium comes after the
white house insisted for days
that the cdc doesn't have the authority
to act and that congress must pass
an extension the house has left for a
multi-week recess
after failing to pass an extension with
pelosi and other top democrats furious
at the white house
for putting this at their feet so bottom
line
this may not hold um it appears as
though the opinion of the supreme court
is that the cdc cannot do an eviction
moratorium
that it must come from congress and
congress is out of session
let's hope that's not the way it goes
down but i think we have to be prepared
for the reality
that it may of course this is an
absolutely crucial thing to do
there are people who even in normal
non-pandemic situations
can't afford an unexpected 400 expense
something like half the country can't
so if you have two three four five even
more months
of rent stacking up and all of a sudden
the protection against getting evicted
goes away you were at real risk of
getting getting evicted now
just one other thing i don't believe
that
the nearly the 11 million or even eight
or nine million would actually
get evicted there are things taking
place at the state level
there are other programs that are
available to some of these people so the
the number really at risk of getting
evicted like in the next month
was nowhere near the 11 million it
doesn't change the importance and
significance of doing this
and now we have to see if it will hold
up in court
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
remember that monday august 16th is the
16th anniversary
of the show and we'll be doing a big
membership special if you'd like to be
notified about it with instructions on
how to take advantage
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video